now by the security minister damian
hines hello to you good morning thank
you so much for joining us on the
program this morning a bit chilly this
morning isn't it and we might all be
turning the heat up a little bit at home
certainly there's a ride between um the
business secretary and also the treasury
um the business secretary is suggesting
that uh government will be looking into
whether to step in to help business
struggling with high energy prices the
treasury ringing uh our sam coats and
say he's just making that up who do you
believe
well this is obviously this is a
difficult situation we've got these
rising uh gas prices globally and that
is difficult that's difficult for some
businesses i think as you mentioned in
your report it's also really really
important we think about the consumer in
this
and the price cap is a really important
part of protection for consumers along
with programs like you know the warm
homes discount
uh and and so on but of course the
business secretary is focused on the
effects on business as as you'd rightly
expect i know quasi is in very regular
talks carries on being in regular talks
with industry including those energy
intensive industries who of course
have been having
support over an extended period
to help to manage their situation as we
move to uh to a lower carbon uh and
eventually a zero carbon
net zero future but does he tell porkys
no of course not so why the treasury
saying he's making things up well these
unnamed sources stories come out from
time to time the fact is government
departments government ministers talk to
each other the whole time and of course
with an issue like this with these
rising global prices and businesses
having to grapple without having to deal
with it for you know to
to to make sure they break even and can
make a margin of course that is
something that the business secretary
and of course the energy secretary is
going to be uh totally focused on
something the treasury of course
is also very very focused on as the
economic uh the economic management
department if you like of the nation so
your understanding is then that the
treasury is potentially um keeping a
watchful eye on whether they need to
step in to support business i think the
treasury is always keeping a watchful
eye right across the economy and so is
the so is the business uh department i
mean we've just had a period where we've
had you know we've used this word
unprecedented a lot over the last couple
of years but the amount of business
support that's gone it's about 100
billion pounds on the business support
aspect really has been
uh you know world leading as well as as
well as unprecedented and you know you
heard again from the prime minister in
his conference speech last week
the private sector industry is the
energy is is the the engine sorry of our
economy it's what creates wealth what
creates jobs it's what you know puts
food on on all of our all of our tables
it's what affords the public services
that we all rely upon
interestingly the head of uk steel is
not as confident as you are about what's
going on he's employed the prime
minister to bang heads together
what do you think
so look the steel sector is one of those
energy intensive industries which of
course has particular
has particular challenges and you know
over the last eight years or so quite a
lot of money has gone in to help to
support those energy-intensive uh
sectors still being one of them there
are others
others as well to deal with um
energy costs and this transition that we
that we have to make to a lower carbon
future and eventually and eventually to
net zero but of course the head of uk
still quite rightly is going to be
concerned about the situation we're in
are going to want to have a lot of focus
on and a lot of workers who are at the
red wall as well will be very concerned
the head of uk steel saying there has to
be longer and longer pauses between
production that must be of some concern
of course of course these things are
concerned there's also been some some
encouraging news of course in the last
uh day or so with uh with with liberty
still but you look at that as a sect and
we know what the
underlying issues are with that sector
particularly this sort of huge global
production much coming from china of
course which does does make it
makes makes the competitive
conditions difficult but
british still uk steel is
particularly high quality products it's
a strategic product as well and
government's been really really clear
over this extent since 2013 when the
support's been going about how important
that is to the whole of our economy now
i remember back in 1973 i'm sure you
don't december 1973 um that it was a
conservative government that introduced
a three-day working week for reasons
that people who were around at the time
will remember
obviously you're not going to go back to
that but is there some sense potentially
of building in a more formal
pause procedure for these big businesses
what do you mean by a formal pause
procedure so he said so we heard from
the head of uk steel who is saying more
and more pauses is there enough is there
a potentially an opportunity for the
prime minister and potentially also the
um chancellor to say you know what
we're going to put those pauses together
and make it four days a week rather than
five days a week working at the moment
no so i mean we live in a country where
you know the government doesn't set you
know doesn't set the pattern of the
working week and right they did in the
1970s well
thank god we've moved past the 1970s and
we have a you know overall we have a an
underlyingly strong economy and we've
seen that in the way we've had this
is this good
well hang on if you hang on if you think
about chaos i mean i know you do
regulate what we've been through what
the whole world's been through this
this shock it's not just been a health
crisis it's been a huge economic shock
as well but actually the way that the
the way the uk economy has has has been
coming back has been has been truly
impressive actually and the way that
employment i mean unemployment hasn't
reached nearly the levels that people
were predicting
12 or 18 months ago we have seen there
is an underlying strength in the
economic course that's the most
important thing
both for all these businesses and the
sectors that that you've been speaking
and of course for families up and down
the country as well but there are
challenges in production as illustrated
and we've just discussed and there are
challenges in trying to make sure
there's enough food on supermarket
shelves to the extent where the prime
minister has come up with a czar to try
to make sure that there aren't gaps on
supermarket shelves for christmas there
are there's uh gaps in having enough raw
road haulage people um and apparently we
wanted 5 000 europeans to come over and
leave on christmas eve i think 27 have
applied so far
we are in a difficult position well okay
there's been a whole series of of things
that the government has come forward
with in support of industry on
some of those supply chain issues and
again look i do have to come back to
this enormous shock that we've had as a
result of the coronavis and all the kind
of knock-on effects that that has had
including you know for example delays to
re-licensing to training programs and so
on for uh for lorry drivers we have as
you know put in place these various
measures to for that
more hgv drivers to come in to bring
forward uh testing and licensing
specifically on the fuel uh the
deployment of military personnel uh to
do that so i mean a whole a whole range
of things but but yeah nobody
nobody diminishes the scale of some of
these challenges and of course it's
absolutely
imperative imperative to get it right
interestingly i was i was walking up a
hill with a lorry driver last week and
he was telling me that um youngsters 17
year olds yep
if they're in the military can drive an
hgv truck
you have to be 21 to do it in civvy
street surely that's something we could
be looking at it's a fair challenge i
wasn't on that hill with you together to
get the rest of that to get the rest of
that conversation all the background
okay look i'm not going to sit here on
the sky and and start making a
pronouncement a question about that
because i don't know i don't know the
three things i think you should be
i don't know the full detail but it is
of course right that we look at all
these
all these uh kind of questions and make
sure we get it right we need to make
sure that all these careers are
attractive careers and they're
attracting the right kind of
numbers of people and we need to make
sure that they are you know sufficiently
well paid as well with sufficiently
attractive conditions to bring people
into those jobs and you know the prime
minister
again you know last week was rightly
talking about a high wage high
productivity economy that's what we need
to be striving for you know extra visas
and stuff bringing people in that is not
the sustainable long-term answer the
sustainable answer is is making sure
these
careers are attractive yeah but
he promised that he'd be watching this
morning i said that i would ask the
minister on his behalf and his and a lot
of other roadhole associations
is it something that seems like a good
idea on the facebook well like i said i
wasn't on the hill
with you the lawyer driver to hear the
rest of the details look on the faces
but on the face of it of course the of
course these are things to these are
things to think about and to make sure
we get that balance right there are
usually reasons why regulations
are in place but it's also right to
challenge them and say are they still
are they still relevant are they still
necessary are they getting in the way of
some other thing that that we need to do
so thank you for thank you thank you to
you and to him or her yeah
for bringing it up there you go steve i
said i would mention it and the minister
she did she'll have a look at it he'll
have a look at it for you and the other
thing to say is somebody else who's up a
hill at the moment is the prime minister
is it right
that he should be on holiday uh when
that the country's going to hell in a
handcuff
well i mean the prime minister is the
prime minister and when you're prime
minister you never stop being
in charge and in touch uh and a phone
call away or these days you know a text
message and whatever whatever else have
you lost his job because of that
away
from from what's going on and the prime
minister never stops being in charge in
charge of government i think it's also
right kay and i think
i think your viewers would tend to agree
with this as well that actually it's
important that people do have
do have a break do have some downtime
and a
pressure and a pressurized job like a
highly pressurized job like the pm's i
think that's probably
you know
even more so the case and family time
and family time is important yeah i'm
sure people don't disagree with that but
it's now the right time
well okay
when when is the right time i mean i
think it's important that it's important
that people do have an opportunity to be
with their families to have some
relaxing unwinding but i wouldn't want
to i wouldn't want to overstate the
amount of unwinding or relaxing that you
get to do as prime minister because as i
say you are constantly in touch you are
constantly being
uh being briefed uh and and yeah and you
remain in charge of the government it is
incredibly it's incredibly high so on
any level that the optics are not good
when people are turning up the heat and
can't really afford it at home and the
pm's sunning himself on a lounge here in
spain
so look
i would come back to what i just said i
mean he remains in charge right he's
that he's the prime minister
and i think it's also right
an important act she's actually
important for him and his family so it's
important for the rest of us actually
for the whole country that uh the the
the prime minister does get to does get
have some family time does get to have
uh does get to have a break so while
he's abroad 1100 people have risked
their lives in two days trying to get to
this country over the weekend um the
french are saying we've not paid the 54
million pounds that we promised them to
help with the policing on that side of
the channel isn't it time we paid up
well we we have a good and constructive
relationship with the french authorities
now i'm not sure the french always agree
with you on that and the work the work
that they do along that coast is
incredibly important and it is
it is life-saving by the way to to stop
people coming across the channel
attempts to come across the channel in
that way and some of these
gangs that make a profit on putting
people's life
in danger they they they haven't seen
these pictures i'm sure yeah they they
they have to be they have to be stopped
i mean it is it is heartbreaking uh to
see this and as i say the french
authorities work is
absolutely invaluable uh in that regard
we do have this arrangement with them
that you mentioned
of providing some resourcing so they
could increase the numbers of uh the
numbers of people uh involved in that
um and we're working out the mechanisms
for uh for that payment that's that's it
and the bank details and give it to them
well well
no
no no no no no no no you really don't
really don't 54 million quid you
promised it to us yeah the pretty patel
went on record to say we are going to
give you this money she actually sat
where you are and made the announcement
why are they still having to ask for it
so i mean this this remains the this
remains the arrangement there's some
administrative so it's going it is going
to arrive yeah there are some
administered arrangements to work from
that that'll that'll happen in the in in
the coming weeks but our the work that
we do in partnership with uh
with french authorities is incredibly is
incredibly important and we would like
it to be
more successful still because there are
still
there are still too many as you rightly
alluded to over the last couple days and
you know it's very dependent on the
weather but um there's still too many
people attempting that life threatening
so when right the money um might then no
longer be having to ask for the money is
it going to be before christmas is it
going to be before the end of the month
look it these things these things will
be worked out i mean there are there are
governmental yeah in the coming weeks
departmental processes that that you go
through and i would expect that to
happen in in the coming weeks i couldn't
tell you exactly which you know exactly
which day or whatever but in the coming
weeks okay and just a quick thought for
our viewers uh on jersey this morning
they're a little bit worried that the
french might stop their fuel supply
aren't they um
do you want to reassure them
yeah france and ourselves are yeah some
of the strongest allies um
in the world before minister with a
great deal of yeah can i just if i may
just interject and make the point that
you know the friend one of the french
ministers said it's time that you brits
grew up you decided that you wanted to
leave brexit you know get on with your
side of the channel um it doesn't sound
to me as though it's a particularly look
well let's be clear and they're
threatening the supply we are getting on
with uh brexit i mean we've done brexit
we have in the famous phrase got brexit
done and now we're looking for really
great in the shops at the moment and now
we are maximizing the opportunities that
there are with trade around the world
with new kinds of
relationships in academia in industry
and so on yes there are by the way there
are also uh supply chain issues they're
not all to deal with brexit by the way i
know it sometimes it suits people to say
that but you know some of these
some of these types of issues are
applying in other countries in different
ways as well where
brexit never came and knocked on their
door so let's let's just reassure the
people in jersey that they won't their
lights will stay on i abs i have
absolute confidence in our relationship
the strength and depth of our
relationship with uh with the republic
of france so the lights will stay on and
they will definitely still happen yes
yes and yes
thank you minister appreciate you taking
the time to join us this morning thank
you very much indeed thank